you made 12 years a slave with Michael
Fassbender yeah and I interviewed him
for one of the x-men films and he
started telling me about his obsession
with shooting BB guns at people on the
set he loves to and and it actually
started to sound like he could put
someone's eye at him I'm something like
a mom from the 1940s but he was firing
BB guns at other actors on the set was
he doing any of that on 12 years of
slave or anything like that he wasn't no
hatefully he was also firing BB guns at
me yeah but but he that's right that's
right there was there was enough going
on but we did go we actually did go
paintballing you know we went out of the
whole group of us you know
oh really in Louisiana one one Saturday
or Sunday and and that was fun with
Michael and Michael's dad was there who
is a terror on the on the field it turns
out people's true nature comes out if
you are on a paintball course and you
are shooting at each other you're real
you know everyone's true nature is
revealed I believe I think that's
probably accurate yeah
yeah and I you know I'd only just at
that point just met Michael's father
then the first thing what he said to me
was cover me and Michael was cheating
you knows how is he cheating how do you
cheat well you know if you get hit you
put your hands up right and then you can
walk all the way through the course
yeah so Michael he's a smart guy yeah he
just put his hands up and walk through
the course shot all of the enemy
combatants wait he would he would put
his hands up say look well I'm out and
then walk out and then shoot them all in
the back Mikey no just Stephen what he
was be walking through them and get to
like a group about 12 of them and be
like actually I'm not
that was affixing throat right he drove
all of these guys messes so actually the
game turned into them really hunting
down Michael Furey ated